quand mike pompéo se rend à minsk et le
1er février dernier
c'est la première visite d'un secrétaire
d'état américain dans le pays en 26 ans
mike pompéo promettait alors de réels
progrès dans la relation avec la
biélorussie
tout en souhaitant défendre sa
souveraineté premières retombées
concrètes de ce rapprochement
la nomination par les états unis le 21
avril de leur première ambassadeur en
biélorussie en plus de 10 ans en 2008
son prédécesseur avait été congédié en
réponse aux sanctions imposées par
l'administration bush
[Musique]
mais la détente du début de l'année de
courte durée le 21 août
alexandre loukachenko a accusé les états
unis de diriger des manifestants qui
s'opposent à sa réélection
c'est dans ce contexte toujours très
tendu que le secrétaire d'état adjoint
américain stephen begun se rend
aujourd'hui en lituanie puis en russie
pour discuter de la situation en
biélorussie
[Musique]
il doit aussi s'entretenir avec svetlana
tikhonov sky à figures de l'opposition
bélarusse aujourd'hui réfugié en
lituanie
[Musique]